sie brauchen jetzt ja schon so ein
bisschen glück dass sie auch
kanzlerkandidat werden könnten oder ja
aber das werden wir jetzt in ruhe alles
besprechen
ich weiß was mit der verantwortung eines
cdu-vorsitzenden verbunden ist der
letzte der das aus nordrhein westfalen
war war konrad adenauer also 2000 kannst
das ist schon sehr sehr lange her aber
ich finde das wählen wir sauber
besprechen mit der csu und markus
symbolisch werden dann zum gegebenen
zeitpunkt einen vorschlag machen sie
haben sich ja viel getroffen in der
letzten zeit markus söder und 7 markus
söder war beim beim neujahrsempfang hat
der freundliche worte für sie gefunden
haben sie das gefühl dass der sünder
dachte naja wenn armin laschet
parteichef wird dann habe ich bessere
chancen kanzlerkandidat zu werden das
glaube ich nicht
das hört man aber so ein bisschen ich
glaube es nicht